this building has engineers it has
scientists and as production staff and
our production staff takes low-grade
agricultural waste like corn stalks
which come into the back of our building
they cook them they sterilize them they
add moisture and then they add the magic
which is our missing em cells and then
we deposit this mixture into molds or
forms and over the next 48 to 96 hours
the Missal 'i'm grossed through these
forms and converts the agricultural
waste into high-grade biological
composites this already has the fungal
mycelium grown throughout it so it's a
combination of vocally source farm waste
this is mostly corn and what you don't
see right now you see little pieces of
is the white mycelium tissue and over
the course of the next four days once
it's in this enclosure it'll transform
this brown matter into its white mass
what's going on here is the fungal
mycelium is already evenly distributed
throughout the entire volume so it
doesn't matter if it's an insulation
panel or protective packaging part it
all takes the same amount of time so our
first commercial product was protective
packaging with the goal of replacing the
the styrofoam or foam plastic that comes
in your mail which is trash essentially
and that products on the market it's
home compostable big brands are using it
you know you may order a product today
that comes with mushroom packaging and
when you're done using it it's a
nutrient it's not a pollutant you can
actually put it in your garden the
packaging we make even though it's home
compostable it doesn't spontaneously
degrade in the mail you know it has to
be broken up and put into the natural
environment to trigger degradation so
this is an example of some recent
surface fairness experimentation we've
been doing basically trying to grow the
fluffiest softest sample for our
electronics customer you can see this is
us setting the one really well so you
could load a level of overgrowth this
one where you're starting to see some
aging of the material is a little more
abrasive and was not a successful
environmental condition so it is an
iterative process and it can take
anywhere from a single iteration which
is always the best but normally it turns
out to be months which equates to eight
to ten of iterations before we have a
product that actually makes it in front
of a customer
and under heat and pressure we've been
able to compress and consolidate these
materials into custom molded forms so
much so that they perform and have the
same structural integrity as a wood
composite that might have these toxic
substances like Hurriyet from aldehyde
we've found a real market pull in molded
composites so for example if you were to
take a desktop organizer that would
normally go through a subtractive
manufacturing process where you're
slowly machining and removing material
that requires a substantial amount of
time labor and of course the the cost of
overhead what we do here at innovative
is we mold those products in the growth
phase and then in the press so we
eliminate the need for any type of post
processing which drives our cost down so
today all the products we sell are
actually below that a traditional
plywood or medium density fiberboard
that would be a subtractive Lee process
we can continue to increase our capacity
here at incubated and that's something
that working to do both optimizing the
equipment that we use in the facility
that you're in today as well as
expanding the space we're actually
expanding in New York as well but it's
true we do need space
we basically trade high throughput high
energy and very expensive processes for
very inexpensive processes that require
more floor space and today we do have an
abundance of floor space particularly as
manufacturing this slowed we're trying
to bring manufacturing back into the
u.s. there's a ample opportunity to
acquire space and luckily anywhere in
this country we can find farm waste
within 500 miles there's going to be a
farm and a raw material attack
applicable to our process
you